Hi this is Clara from the Pirate Union The Crous elections are approaching and today
I present you the good reasons to vote pirate union First,
we are the only left-wing list to run and today it is
necessary to block the extreme right.
To from voting is to leave them 1 seat in all the commissions of the Crous.
In addition,
our main objective is to fight for the improvement and
preservation of your student rights,
so it concerns you directly.
Finally,
voting pirate union is registering in 1 national uh line with
1 student running in all regions of France.
You can find all our detailed measurements on our
Instagram account And don't forget,
from 6 to 08/02 you vote pirate union,
green and solidarity.